hi
welcome come on in it's cold out there
hi i'm beth this is tom i'm tom
we've been married for 30 years and this
is our living room
first i'd like to introduce to you all
the artwork on the walls
these are all well most of it has been
done by tom
the parking lot paintings came about
because i i do
walk everywhere and i love the beauty of
how
the lines degrade and so i
tried to capture that feeling of um
age and degradation in the
in the paint
this is where we feed everybody
breakfast or dinner we love sit down
dinners
one of the things i really love doing in
my living room is hosting people
we figure we've been hosting since about
1999 and we've hosted about 350 people
from
20 countries
there's no way that i can truly explain
how
important these words are to me
thanks for coming and visiting us i
would love to have you come back and
visit us
we'll be happy to show you antioch
nashville
doors always open door is always open
and usually there's some food waiting so
come
come back and enjoy us bye